prince harry and meghan markle made
their first joint appearance in several
months in the pursuit of helping those
affected by the coronavirus pandemic
since this pandemic began we've been
talking to the experts about how we can
do our part
this week we sat with independent growth
health leaders to further understand how
we get closer to vaccine equity
and ending this health crisis over the
weekend the couple fulfilled an
important mission during their trip to
new york city taking the stage in
central park where 60 thousand people
turned out for global citizen live
and while in this country and many
others you can go almost anywhere and
get vaccinated billions of people around
the world cannot harry and megan were
seen holding hands and making each other
laugh this was their first public outing
together since the arrival of their
daughter lillabet in june
there has never been a greater need for
advocacy
than there is right now
the event joined a 24-hour broadcast
with cities around the world i couldn't
come home without doing this one
[Music]
j-lo shawn mendes and coldplay were just
some of the night's highly anticipated
musical acts harry and meghan are here
rachel brosnahan also spoke at the event
telling et that she was more than a
little nervous about her royal proximity
i had the
the curse of following them on stage
nobody wanted that job so they gave it
to me i had pictures of prince harry as
a youth on my bedroom wall
it was the moment i'm i'm blushing
underneath all this
makeup saturday night was the final stop
on the couple's multi-day cross-country
trip
that's megan and harry kicking off their
visit on thursday stopping by one world
observatory at the world trade center
followed by the 9 11 museum and memorial
less than two weeks after the 20th
anniversary of september 11th the next
day the couple dropped by this public
school in harlem where megan read her
book the bench to a group of second
grade students the duke of sussex was
seen taking a seat on the ground
alongside the children harry and megan
took photos with the kids even giving
out some royal high fives
[Music]
you